yeah I can I was about to get real no
I'm gonna get up I'm gonna kind of just
say this real quick and um you know on
what I posted a photo a couple of days
ago this is maybe a week ago and there
was a commenter who really hurt my
feelings and they responded to him you
read your comments yes yeah this one
really got to me I you know I'm gonna
let you speak yeah I just want to
interject okay my feelings it's so hurt
I know that I can't even yeah and I
responded to him and then he responded
back again with a longer thing what do
you say well how can I just read it yeah
you're just giving him you're going to
that's what I knew that does is no we're
gonna still give out his name I'm not
gonna say his name yeah what he has no
this person that commented has no photos
on his always they're always Graham he
has really no followers and then he
follows like 20 people yeah I want to
know what hurts you go ahead the other
one yeah but you're involved in it oh
[ __ ] I don't want to hear this is what
he said though do we just do it okay
right new material you you has been
comedian
right then and there don't mention my
name I'm not gonna and don't let your
gold-digging girlfriend right before you
she's she's funnier than you I'll take
that gold yeah that was yeah that was
and then it's so crazy because as soon
as and then I said okay I said some like
that you said okay no I'm gonna trying
to find it but that's the reason why I
can't find my comment is because no
because over a hundred people respond
responded defending me well that's nice
yeah I mean just like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that boy or I'm just reading Abril [ __ ]
David's girl then [ __ ] on his carpet
right um okay lol hater Bobby
damn my family and I love you don't go
up now can I read it as Chris Hansen Wow
okay so here let me just stop for a
second let me just go for the beginning
then there's so many
Wow I mean look 73 I mean just read
literally itself yeah any of any of them
here you have glasses but you don't know
how to read yeah I think you're dyslexic
I'll show you my reading skill alright
what when I do yeah oh yeah this is a
bad idea for me to do oh my god Jarrod
Camacho 18 twist this is actually George
Oh George yeah is that you Trish Tyson
writes at David 2013 you are the problem
very good as but why do you why do we
get so sensitive I don't know uh that's
not healthy no I mean it's it's sort of
like I unexpected because you know we're
kind of making things for free that mad
like I have got to let this person know
that I don't like them or something it
just feels you get up with the Trump
stuff sometimes yeah and I try not to
make it political I don't want it I you
know ah strives anybody what but you
know the worst ones though yeah the ones
that hurt me the most when like hey man
love your stuff you're great but this
one will kind of sucked like when
they're like rah know that they're there
like trying to try to be this really
does this really must suck if they look
if they're like wow and because you
spent so much time riding it and putting
it up there and yeah I know but it's
it's so weird because when I look at
someone like Joe Rogan yeah I feel like
he doesn't give a [ __ ] doesn't that's
great and I think I'm getting there a
little bit like I feel like now I'm
that's ignorant
yeah I'll tell you why that's personal
right because I don't have any new
material I don't write a lot and so
that's number two what made me mad about
it was bringing her into it yeah pretty
yeah impenetrable at this point yeah
more successful you get the more they
come out and one I like you know take a
little piece of yeah
or if you're female I feel like even on
this having this podcast every time we
have a female guest who I think just
knocks it out of the park we
collectively think that would that was
an amazing when Whitney did our podcast
we afterwards when she left I was like
that could have been the best yeah that
was amazing yeah and it was it was it
was blood it was a it was a blood felt
but every female guess we've had on here
Jasha bloody it's like here's a theory
it's a angst boys who aren't getting
laid and and there's some energy extra
energy against women because they're
just like got some frustration and anger
Jackson I don't have and I've said this
before any feeling of that toward women
I never have I've never like when I see
like what I remember back in the day
when Ellen did her first
half hour this is probably in the 80s
and my parents has just got an HBO and
when I saw her first half-hour I went I
had like a spiritual awakening mm-hmm
and they were all joked that she didn't
do what I generally liked which is back
then you know I was also introduced to
like Bill what's his name
Cosby Napa no the one that died off hey
Bill Hicks
so Hicks what you know was around new
but I watched him on HBO as well and I
went but still I went this girl is so
silly and her she's hurt she's a good
drunk rider I've never seen jokes like
that so absurd in that way and um I
really love I love her I love to see her
live mm-hmm and then I would tell
friends I go you got to check out this
Ellen DeGeneres thing and they're like
[ __ ] that girl and then you're like what
no I won't watch it she's a girl
they're girls not funny and then you're
like you're a kid right you're in high
school right you're like that's
ridiculous why does anybody have that in
them as a guy
[Music]